zum tagesgespräch war phoenix begrüße
ich ganz herzlich katharina bald die
vize-präsidentin des eu-parlaments größe
in schweich in ihrem wahlkreis
stimmt
also es gibt das versagen des westens
dass in diesen tagen immer wieder betont
wird und dann gibt es im westen also
hier in der eu
mitgliedstaaten die sagen wir nehmen
keine flüchtlinge wo stehen wir denn
eigentlich momentan
leider ist die frage von flucht und asyl
ja eine die in der europäischen union
schon lange kontrovers diskutiert wird
wo wir schon eigentlich jahrzehnte
versuchen gemeinsam grund zu finden
innerhalb der mitgliedstaaten ist schon
sehr sehr lange nicht gelingt und
insofern trifft diese diese lage jetzt
die europäische union in einer in einer
kritischen situation wir haben auch noch
die slowenische ratspräsidentschaft also
ein land was sie immer schon sehr
kritisch manchmal hetzerisch gegenüber
migranten und migrantinnen geäußert hat
das wird schon eine sehr sehr schwierige
operation
leider mehrere regierungen die auf dem
rücken von geflüchteten die letzten
jahre politik gemacht haben es wird eine
schwierige aufgabe da alle an einen
tisch zu bringen also man will ja da
eigentlich ungern immer darüber reden
muss aber darüber reden jetzt sagt die
uno mit einer zahl von einer halben
million mal so einen richtwert wir
wissen von 2,2 millionen die bereits aus
afghanistan raus gezogen sind und in den
nachbarländern untergekommen sind womit
rechnen sie dann rechnen sie auch mit
solchen zahlen und wo sollen die hin
na das sind die zahlen von menschen die
versuchen sich in sicherheit zu bringen
vor den taliban
aber das sind natürlich nicht die zahlen
die dann am ende
weite wege auf sich nehmen können zum
teil auch oder wollen um weit entlegene
länder zu kommen also das hat die
europäische union und die internationale
staatengemeinschaft gelernt dass in
aller erster linie die geflüchteten da
versorgt werden müssen wo sie an landen
das wird jetzt hauptsächlich der landweg
seien über die gefühle wird nicht mehr
viel gehen das heißt also die
nachbarstaaten zu unterstützen
bisher war afghanistan
das größte empfängerland was
entwicklungsgelder angeht diese gelder
werden natürlich jetzt nicht an die
taliban ausgezahlt die müssen dafür
verwendet werden um die situation in den
nachbarländern wo die geflüchteten
ankommen für sie möglichst gut zu
gestalten also so gehen beispielsweise
mit ursula von der leyen mit und sagen
sichere fluchtrouten schaffen und dann
aber bitte behaltet sie dort im umfeld
von afghanistan bitte nicht hier her
naja so so würde ich das nicht
formulieren das ist ja nicht nur im
interesse jetzt von von regierungen oder
mitgliedsstaaten sondern die menschen
die nichts mehr haben zum teil die alles
zurücklassen müssen zum teil mit mit
kleinen kindern unterwegs sind die
machen sich ja nicht aus jux und
dollerei auf einen weg durch durch viele
länder über tausende von kilometern
sondern was die suche ist sicherheit und
das wissen wir aus aus leider vielen
vielen konflikten dass sie die natürlich
erst mal in der nähe ihrer heimat suchen
und die länder die bereits sind dort
geflüchtete aufzunehmen die haben jede
unterstützung verdient und das ist auch
gut und richtig so es gibt menschen für
die wir eine besondere verantwortung
haben auch da sind sich zumindest in
deutschland alle einig das sind die
ortskräfte und ihre angehörigen das sind
auch menschen die aufgrund von
besonderen engagement sich in besondere
gefahr befinden frauenrechtlerinnen
kritische journalisten ja viele andere
und da hat ja sogar gestern der
bayerische innenminister
die verantwortung deutschlands und
europas auch betont und ich hoffe dass
wir zumindest für diese
personengruppen auch einen konsens in
europa finden denn da können sich selbst
die konservativen bis rechtsausleger
regierungen noch darauf verständigen da
können sie sich noch durchringen dass es
menschen gibt für die wände spezifische
verantwortung haben das ist meine
hoffnung dass es in gewissen
minimalkonsens geben kann innerhalb der
europäischen union werden natürlich eine
gelände weiteres tun ja gut also das ist
ja der unterschied das eine sind die
flüchtenden die aus verschiedenen
gründen aus den ländern aus
beispielsweise in afghanistan raus
kommen dann gibt es die schutz die
schutzsuchenden diejenigen die für uns
ortskräfte waren für den westen ok
bleiben wir noch dabei sie sagen da
könnte man konsens hinkriegen da ist
eigentlich klar dass wir dafür
verantwortung haben ja wir haben aber
auch verantwortung für ihren weg heraus
wie schaut's damit aus
ja wie gesagt der luft weg ist jetzt
abgeschnitten nachdem die us amerikaner
den flughafen geräumt haben das heißt
das geht derzeit für die menschen die
sich in sicherheit bringen wollen nur
aus dem auf dem landweg nach aus
afghanistan heraus sie müssen in die
nachbarländer kommen und das ist dann
die einzige möglichkeit für diejenigen
die in anderen ländern schutz bekommen
sollen sie von diesen ländern aus nach
in die jeweiligen länder zu holen kann
er da zum beispiel hat sich bereits
verpflichtet 20.000 menschen aufzunehmen
auch die us einer ähnlichen
größenordnung und da wäre es natürlich
sinnvoll dass man wenn man sich sowieso
klar darüber ist dass man diese menschen
aufnehmen will sie jetzt nicht zu fuß
durch sechs länder laufen ist sondern
sondern ihnen sichere fluchtrouten
ermöglicht also ihnen eine eine
gesicherte möglichkeit
eröffnet und nach deutschland zu kommen
wenn die sicherheitsüberprüfungen
geordnet stattfinden sollen dann muss
man ja auch dafür sorgen dass man weiß
wo die menschen sind die man aufnehmen
will ich denke auch da sollte sich die
internationale staatengemeinschaft
koordinieren wie gesagt kann er da
20.000 schon zugesagt die usa auch und
da werden wird sollte die internationale
gemeinschaft staatengemeinschaft an
einem strang ziehen ich hoffe auch die
eu-minister da hoffen wir auch darauf
dass die eu innenminister heute da mit
einer stimme sprechen dankeschön
katarina barley